we've a mission for you
at pg-13 get your tickets no justice
the Empire's building a weapon capable
of destroying an entire planet they call
it the Death Star need to capture the
glance if there's any hope of destroying
it we want to help all right how many do
I need I'll be there for you the captain
said I had to tell them that we are
dealing with you is immeasurable I will
not sell
the Imperial forces are converging on my
present location
take hold of this moment
the force is strong
tell me you have a back-up plan
may the force be with us
one a Star Wars story
you almost got me no welcome pretty
pg-13 in theaters December 16th on your
own from the age of 15 reckless and
undisciplined this is a rebellion isn't
it i repel with a mission for you
we want to help
this is our chance to make a real
difference I couldn't face myself if I
give up now
we're not used to people sticking around
when things go back this is the first
for me
rogue one a Star Wars story rated pg-13
in theaters and IMAX 3d December 16th
vampires building a weapon capable of
destroying an entire planet we have to
capture the plans if there's any hope of
destroying it how will you do it you
make 10 men feel like a hundred
welcome to rogue one
if the Empire has this kind of power
what chance do we have
rebellions are built on hope the
Empire's building or terrible weapon I
need your help
can stop them
this is your chance to make a real
difference
rebellions of built on
are you with me
they call it the Deathstar
is capable of destroying an entire
planet if the Empire has this kind of
power
what chance do we have the question is
what choice
we have
be with me
robe one a Star Wars story at a pg-13
you